le compte à rebours a commencé dans
quelques heures les bars et les
restaurants de la cité phocéenne devons
baisser leurs rideaux et ce pour une
durée de 15 jours
une décision qui survient alors que le
gouvernement a placé marseille en zone
d' alerte maximale
la ville détient le record en france
métropolitaine de taux d'incidence de la
maladie avec 281 cas pour 100000
habitants alors que le ministre de la
santé olivier ferrand défend des
annonces nécessaire mais pas arbitraire
ici dans ce restaurant en face du vieux
port c'est un sentiment d'injustice qui
prédomine ben oui pourquoi nous croient
que nous pourquoi parise ont laissé
jusqu'à 22h pourquoi et pourquoi pas
nous qu'est-ce qu'on a eu de différence
avec karine aucune jeudi rené
restaurateurs comme à paris donc je vois
pas pourquoi pas paris ni par pas le
reste et nous oui
non je comprends pas et parmi les
clients de ce restaurant
certains sont venus aujourd'hui apporter
leur soutien aux restaurateurs
on est des touristes on est passé à tous
à marseille pour venir au mucem et on a
su effectivement que les restaurants
fermés est vraiment par solidarité on
est venu manger au restaurant
aujourd'hui puisqu'on avait prévu un
pique nique dans le coffre et quand on a
su que c'était le dernier service et
bien on est venu effectivement parce que
c'est compliqué certains professionnels
du secteur appellent à la désobéissance
ce que comprend parfaitement
c'est propriétaire d'un salon de thé
dans les quartiers sud de marseille
on n'a vraiment pas le choix donc quand
on nous dit de fermer bon moi je vais
quand même un peu restée ouverte en
masse parce que j'ai la livraison
emportés mais si on me dit de fermer
totalement je pense que je serais pas
capable parce que finalement c'est on
n'a pas le choix c'est son travail soit
on ferme totalement ferme vraiment pour
demander quoi bon alors on met la clé
sous la porte ou simplement ils se
rendent vraiment pas content fait plus
de temps que ça nous prend ça nous prend
toute une vie donc c'est facile de dire
de fermer mais derrière on a une famille
on a deux enfants on à voir si notre vie
en occident ces deux dernières années
ont été particulièrement difficiles pour
le secteur entre la baisse du tourisme
les grèves les menaces d'attentât et
maintenant ces deux crises sanitaires
certains démons sainte deux poids deux
mesures alors que bon nombre d'activités
restent ouvertes alors ceux qui
décideraient donné c'est leur
établissement ouvert malgré cette
interdiction s'expose à des grands
risques comme des amendes dissuasives la
fermeture obligatoire de leur
établissement pendant six mois et même à
des peines de prison avec sursis mais
certains avec qui nous avons parlé ici
nous ont confié qu'ils étaient prêts à
prendre le risque
il s'agit désormais d'une question de
survie